hello hello and welcome to New rockstars
my name is Anna vanson and after eight
years since the announcement that a Five
Nights at Freddy's movie would be made
several painting of hands and a few
weeks we have finally gotten a teaser
for the movie now the game that this is
based on has a large fan base filled
with folks theorizing trying to uncover
lore and solve timelines and while I've
been watching those videos alongside
others for years today we're going to be
breaking down the trailer in a way that
doesn't spoil the plot for those who
haven't played the games as far as the
plot goes I'll only be discussing the
basic premise of the game's story
warning though I already know the
comments section is going to be the Wild
Wild West so be careful when going down
there if you don't want plot points
revealed for those who are big fans of
the games don't worry there are plenty
of Easter eggs and hidden details in
here for you to enjoy too so to set
things up for those unfamiliar Five
Nights at Freddy's is based on a game
series of the same name created by Scott
cawthorne who also wrote and co-produced
this movie minute you play as Mike
Schmidt a newly hired security guard
taking over the night shift at Freddy
Fazbear's Pizza a fictional Family
Restaurant based largely on Chuck E
cheese this establishment is known for
its colorful cast to performing
animatronics including Freddie the bear
Bonnie the rabbit Chica the Chicken who
holds Mr Cupcake and Foxy the Fox
Firefox there's also golden Freddy who's
in the game but doesn't perform on stage
like the rest of them and who you don't
come across as much as the others anyway
when animatronics start moving on their
own Mike has to survive Five Nights at
Freddy's with that onto a trailer
welcome to Freddy Fazbear's pizzeria
where fantasy and fun come to life I
love when you can get a sense of the
type of movie it's going to be from the
first second of the teaser and before
anything else happens we get the sound
and static of a VHS tape starting up not
only letting us know that we're about to
see old footage but evoking an eerie
feeling connected to the Trope of
finding old tapes and other horror media
one of the more notable examples being
the VHS tape in the ring so already we
have a sense of unease and some context
for what era we're in which is echoed in
the 4x3 format of the video we then see
in the video a gal named Kim welcomes us
to Freddy Fazbear's pizzeria where
fantasy and fun come to life a line said
for legal reasons in a phone recording
that's been left for you by the previous
security guard in the first game during
this you can also hear a common musical
Motif from the games that is based on
the famous toriador song from the Opera
Carmen
in the games it's most well known for
playing when the power goes out and
you're waiting in the dark for someone
to come get just one other thing to put
fans on it while watching this taking a
quick look at Kim's pins we can see a
pizza pattern pin a checkered pattern
pin which is a pattern seen throughout
the restaurant in the game that's also
reflected on the walls behind Kim a
Freddy pin a pin that says the let's eat
phrase that's on chica's bib one with a
bunch of balloons on it pins that have
chica foxy Mr Cupcake and Bonnie and a
pin with the whole gang on it moving on
to the following shots we get colorful
striped party hats reminiscent of the
party hats on the tables in several of
the games some killer harem pants a kid
holding a foxy plush which is actually
the official sanchi plush and a couple
of kids playing on a kicks brand bubble
foosball table and I actually found an
old advertisement for this exact model
with a patent number and looking up that
patent number shows you that it was made
in 1984. this kid's definitely losing by
the way in the following shot we can see
from left to right a king Rock pinball
cabinet from 1972 a royal flush pinball
cabinet from 1976 the kids are playing
on a 1980 centipede cabinet and the lime
green outline and front panel lead me to
believe that this is an Area 51 cabinet
which came out in 1995. this morning
eyebrows of some hardcore fans that are
certain that this is supposed to be in
the 80s but I just
I found it could be a prop error I don't
know we then have a couple kids playing
in a ball pit and it may be no
coincidence that the camera is at an
angle where the net in front of them
almost makes it feel like they're in a
cage because the net stops here it
doesn't surround the whole ball pit but
they chose to frame it like this hit it
guys
a bizarrely stiff-armed Kim hits a
Showtime button that's a call back to a
non-functional Showtime button and Five
Nights at Freddy's help wanted and the
iconic purple curtain opens to Freddy
Chica and Bonnie identical to how they
are in the game aside from chica holding
Mr Cupcake in her right hand instead of
her left which might have just been
switched for practical filming purposes
but aside from that even the circular
clouds in the background look just like
the ones from the First Games trailer
and the lights are the same colors and
move in the same way that they were
going to for the cut Showtime
performance and help wanted and let's
talk about these animatronics they opted
to go for practical effects with the
animatronics enlisting Jim Henson's
Creature Shop to make these giant
characters which is a good call because
if I saw sweetums or really any gym
handsome character in a dark corner I
would piss myself but these animatronics
look identical to their in-game
counterparts and I can't wait to see
them in action the song that plays is
talking in your sleep by The Romantics
released in 1983 and the particular line
they play is I hear the secrets that you
keep ominous we made this video with the
help of geology and with their help you
can make your skin healthier than ever
geology is a 22 time award-winning skin
hair and body care company recognized in
men's health Oprah daily hypebeast
birdie Esquire and GQ their products are
built around just a handful of powerful
proven ingredients that have entrusted
by dermatologists for decades just take
a quick 30 second diagnostic quiz in
geology will create a simple and
effective skin care or hair care routine
customized just for you geology's
co-wash and deodorant are great and I
use them all the time but right now
they're running a special offer for a
skin care sampler pack and glg's Skin
Care stuff is in a league of its own
geology's line of skin care products can
help you fight acne reduce oiliness
prevent wrinkles combat dark or puffy
under eyes have smoother hydrated skin
and Target signs of aging there has
never been a better time to try geology
even right now for a very limited time
use code rockstars 100 to get 100 off
your personalized 30 days skin care
sample set all you have to do is cover
the 495 for shipping on top of that new
rockstars fans get an exclusive bonus
offer up to 50 off on an additional skin
hair or body product of your choice when
you add it to your trial click the link
in the description or go to
geolog.i.e rockstars100 to get started
if you're watching this video
it means you've been selected as
Freddy's newest security guard we then
cut away from the tape to an abandoned
and overgrown parking lot outside the
building clearly several years later
with a busted sign saying closed it's
interesting to note that the sign has
one letter off to the side and five
letters grouped together with one of
them standing out from the rest the
person
though ring we see Josh Hutcherson as
Mike wearing a very relaxed outfit as a
voiceover from the tape says if you're
watching this video it means you've been
selected as Freddie's newest security
guard cementing that they are following
the plot of Mike being the newest
security guard on the job assumingly to
prevent trespassers from breaking in we
get a wide shot from an angle akin to a
security cameras likely no mistake as
the game relies heavily on switching
back and forth between camera footage
and what better production company to
bring that to life than blumhouse who
launched security camera footage to
horror Fame with Paranormal Activity
this angle also contributes to making
Mike Feel small and isolated compared to
the enormous looming Darkness he's
facing but let's brighten the shot up
and take a look at some of the details
first off the layout is horrendous
imagine trying to navigate those booths
when it's crowded that's the real
nightmare but moving along the room has
the iconic checkered flooring with some
carpet that makes me want to go back to
Skate World so badly there are also
Chica and Bonnie stained glass panels on
the booze and potentially a Freddy one
in back too a bulletin board of kids
drawings which are seen throughout the
games a let's eat neon sign next to the
kitchen which is technically in the
first game although only audio works for
that camera and a price counter much
like the price Corner in Five Nights at
Freddy's 2 or the price counter and help
wanted taking a closer look in there
there's a red and green shirt though I
couldn't find official merch that
matched up yet a Freddy and Bonnie mask
along the outside and maybe a chica one
it's that or a backpack or something a
few foxy and Freddy plushes and what
looks to be a Freddy backpack up top her
rest is a bit too fuzzy to make out for
now Mike pulls back the curtain in a
classic horror movie suspense move to
reveal Bonnie and we get an idea for the
size of these things but while
animatronics may look like friendly
cartoon characters at the Forefront it
is much more unnerving to see the wiring
and metal endoskeletons that make them
function which is what we see when he
pans to Freddy
we're going to have so much fun together
as Mike flips the power on there's a
celebrate poster originating from the
first game in the background and then
the main sign that reads Freddy
Fazbear's Pizza place and you can
definitely see the Chuck E cheese
influence here now people are ready to
burn down the place when this sign was
originally revealed online and they saw
that Freddy was wearing gloves I don't
know why he's wearing gloves on the sign
but not in the movie but my best guess
as to why they gave him gloves on the
sign is either a the same reason Mario
originally got gloves to make it easier
to distinguish his hands from the rest
of his body or B Because practically if
you were driving down the highway a
white waving light would get your
attention more than a brown waving light
and Russians are all about pulling
hungry customers in we're then treated
to the security office AKA your home in
the first game and this being where you
spend the entirety of the first game
they made sure to get the details right
when the poster to the fans of the cup
right down to the crumpled up foil
there's a picture with Freddy and the
gang up on the wall and a letter from
management that reads make sure to
follow all rules I'm guessing to avoid
unnecessary damage to something the
security camera monitors show the ball
pit in Game Area a corridor with
potentially something
the stage area a party room where the
tables are angled very similarly to
party room 3 and Five Nights at Freddy's
2 a maintenance Hall the Supply Closet
the Bonnie hides in in the game and the
screen next to it has the front doors
the parking lot perhaps the side or back
lot and another maintenance Hall and the
stage camera that we see in the next
shot is a one for one of the stage
camera from the first game we then see
Mike looking around before the camera
reveals that Freddy is there too I think
this one's a sneaky editing trick
considering we don't actually see him
say the voiced over hello meaning he
might not say it at that point and
Freddie's eyes aren't glowing red which
although red eyes do appear in Help
Wanted seems to be the way this movie is
going to demonstrate the animatronics
level of aggro so it's possible he
already knows Freddy's there it cuts
back to the training tape and aside from
two of the people from the previous
shots being gone the only thing a Miss
is how Kim is shaking her head while
saying we're going to have so much fun
together blink twice Kim we see someone
locked into a chair before showing Mike
looking down the barrel of some saws and
this is another sneaky trailer misdirect
because the person in the the first two
shots is not Mike since Mike was wearing
a casual attire and those are older
hands no shade and if you're thinking he
might have just changed clothes this
image released by blumhouse shows that
nope he still isn't wearing the suit and
tie so the person in the first two shots
is almost certainly the security guard
we see later in the trailer obviously
not to say that Mike isn't in the
scenario at some point because clearly
he is and we can see from the trailer in
that photo that this is the inside of a
Freddy head which differs from the game
a little but serves to be pretty deadly
nonetheless whether these inner workings
and strappy chair were built for
torturous purposes or perhaps to keep an
endoskeleton still while the head was
attached we'll have to see but either
way not great for humans then it quickly
flashes through a montage over the sound
of maniacal laughing now there's no
shortage of creepy children laughing
sound effects but it also slightly
resembles the fredbear plush from Five
Nights at Freddy 4 sped up hahaha
extended version of the balloon boy
character laugh
maybe it's just me but in that Montage
we see Foxy's Shadow a girl who we know
from IMDb is named Abby played by Piper
Rubio who many speculate as a
replacement for Mike's sister Elizabeth
in the games a shot of Freddy activating
his eyes notably turning orange and not
red and a shot of a character listed as
Vanessa played by Elizabeth lale who
fans were surprised to see given the
character isn't in the first three games
I mentioned the first three games
because Matthew Lillard said in a meet
and greet that the movie is based on the
first three games her hair being back
tight like that shows that she's likely
a type of Public Safety Officer movies
and shows don't put women's hair back
tight like that for no reason trust
we're then shown a very surreal moment
where Mike turns to face five kids in
the woods each kid pretty clearly
representing an animatronic bunny ears
being Bonnie orange hair and shirt and
hook being foxy Hill and white outfit
being Chica and there's a huge amount of
debate over which is which but the other
two being Freddy and potentially golden
Freddy some people think this kid is
meant to represent golden Freddy because
of his blonde hair and the fact that the
rest of the kids are in a line and he's
the only one out in front of them so
people think this kid is meant to be
golden Freddy because his shirt has
yellow and purple in it and he's hidden
from sight in that first shot that some
people think he's meant to represent
another character altogether
disagreements in my Five Nights at
Freddy's
unheard of we see Matthew Lillard as
William Afton who we aren't given much
of in this teaser aside from his
Intelligence being displayed by the
diplomas on his wall what we do know is
that he won't be having a British accent
like in the games which Lillard
disclosed in that same meet and greet as
before and there's a
that's what you see
as he looks up at assuming
electronic him being pressed up against
the gate with the exit door right behind
him paints this beautiful picture that
his salvation was so close yet so far as
he tried to escape only to find the gate
to be locked what appears to be Foxy's
leg then crushes a ball as the lights
turn purple and what is vaguely running
innocent of the power outage sound from
the game plays
similarly everything goes quiet as Abby
Ducks into the ball pit to hide she's
also wearing a different sweater than
before showing that Five Nights at
Freddy's might live up to its name or
the girls layered um we see Foxy's eye
glowing red and our final two shots are
of Freddy and Bonnie standing over
something or someone and it could
totally just be the lighting but one of
Bonnie's people seems to be glowing a
bit brighter of a purple than the other
and that was the Five Nights at Freddy's
teaser what'd you think I personally
can't wait until we can get a full
trailer so I can get some more juicy
info until then you can follow me on
Twitter at it'sanna vanson and follow us
up to new rockstars add new rockstars
for more breakdowns of everything you
love sweet dreams
I don't know where I'm going are you on
the run from a mafia Hitman because your
wife likes to play the ponies but she
sucks at it do you love your wife but
wish you'd study horse racing instead of
just picking names that sound cute then
you need to take a tour a Tommy tour
Tommy cures is a new weekly info came in
experience where I Tom tours will take
you on a tour of the universe's hottest
slow Cals be there
thank you
[Music]